welcome to this video a gala in the
house they're one of the most frequent
opponents let's see yes lets me take
that okay quite interesting what do we
get now maybe here so kind of english
english opening I wonder now this is
played actually d4 is probably a bit
lame yeah I'd like to play it with d3 or
something maybe I should prepare that
can this end we should be three
No okay we can always play b6 which is
some quite Mike useful anyway yeah um
okay so still why do I put the bishop I
was thinking that maybe like he Ray 492
and possibly 9485 so let's start like
this and open up this diagonal now 94
and possibly a five is on the on the
agenda maybe he can play something
aggressive like 'if I've f5f for this
kind of thing now or that also so let's
put it here and then shoot for this a 5
move if possible a 5 he will probably go
be five but ok then I have a six so a
five let's say he goes h4 I can play a
5a 5b five a six should be good okay so
we get so we get some trades and let's
take him Bishop cheeks oh and now he
wants to hear let's let's take go if I
that was the idea all along a sh for of
course here so that the test some point
okay so if i take it 1b six I mean
it's probably going for b5 it's
difficult to prevent but okay I should
probably should take any way now maybe
just here right
if he plays b5 on my cheek play would be
one now it feels very equal but the
immediate rugby ones probably not not
very useful i also have deform that
could be an idea actually take stakes
and then possibly roxy one roxy five now
probably not leading to much anyway
Jim the dis deform move maybe see far
before looks looks bad that that doesn't
help at all
Queen a 3 however what about Queen a 3a
checking c5 is Bishop t6 and so let's do
this and gain some central space
and we're interesting there let move I
completely overlooked
yeah where am I going now interesting I
really didn't see that move at all so
let's have a look edge Froy make let go
H for him let's do this I'm bishop d 284
why is he going for before immediately
playing this a bit a bit yeah but I
don't know but passively in some way
so if i go e4 here probably here and
then if all this really is some kind to
play he might play it for himself yeah
yeah okay let's I go there no one if I
go there but if I take it as taking it
bad drug B 1 and Row look a 1 i'm not
sure how bad this is okay it might be
bad in terms of practical play because
of the time did I get the king over to
see to it that's not so bad before it's
not not particularly great the spawn I
cannot attack it at the moment but it
will be a factor later before maybe
yeah maybe just before of course you can
go yeah I can do something like that
time morning before work 8-5 now check
didn't expect that check that looks okay
now as I said if what might be affected
later and here it is one you can
probably play how can you draw now a
group picture maybe that's not so clear
check that might be the way to draw Rock
g5 winning this pawn or is this too
greedy let's do that check
JK Shin I can let's not do that check
its let's get those pawns rolling check
for g5 check check check check check
mate oh ok yeah that was a strange game
where I was some worse for some time him
ok I think yeah I don't really think I
was here wit it turned out to be a
problem because I I really did not did
not CC Freud all it's a simple move but
I simply simply didn't didn't register
with me and yeah that's a bit
uncomfortable I always has this
potential see porn passer and turn I
don't really have any any clear-cut plan
to this guy and then our they're so
interesting that's an interesting way to
play here yeah I already have my doubts
here if this is if this is all great but
like it's definitely better here just a
matter of how much the computer is not
that pessimistic gives 0.14 black but
gives the rook c8 now and then he five
yeah Nia black black must be okay his
king is more active he's got a better
Bishop and he's got a potential passport
yeah maybe this move for before now this
this this year could be problematic very
quickly but where did he screw up I mean
this this looks totally fine probably
before that channeled even there is a
problem that is the problem he's got a
look before then that's a funny move and
this is still ok check engine gives 0 0
0 0 which is not totally evident that
still looks like quite an interesting
position but maybe I get in King situ
and there's no way forward for black now
that's very much probably very problem
yeah after that I'm Josiah check much
better dear c3 check yeah but this this
was a bit weird I thought you would do
dad that's actually very interesting I
have tons of pawns but the sea pawn is
very dangerous the computer is giving
0.7 which is an interesting valuation it
feels like it should be something clear
in some way but maybe yeah it's
difficult I know that the evil galas
goes up with increasing depth 1.2 now
yeah maybe the pawns are too strong
that's difficult to analyze now but this
is definitely a mistake because here I'm
just just picking up stuff check yeah
Jim
I just have a winning at game here with
the very healthy Palmer's on the King
side okay well thanks for watching